it's been an interesting time for
american politics
this month alone so i thought it'd be
fun to do it try not to laugh
for family guy roasting everything
american let's swing into action people
peter i don't understand how they just
let you out of jail
yeah joe had all kinds of evidence
against you guys seems like a huge
miscarriage of justice well i thought if
you do something wrong you're supposed
to get punished oh chris
not if you're white
oh crap the lapd
[Music]
come on peter i want to save some tape
for the hollywood sign
okay hey thanks a lot you guys hey our
pleasure have a nice vacation sir
hey guys
[Music]
is
you don't come back ever i know like you
american and all you americans look
alike
oh we all look alike do we well look
who's talking
good evening tonight's top story quahog
is infested
with loud hairy creatures also known as
new yorkers
they migrate north every autumn to see
the foliage and i think i speak for all
of us when i say that new york and
everyone from there can fornicate
themselves with an iron stick
if you want to learn more about our
president consult the steele dossier
which is
all about impedance he also with whole
heart and full throat endorsed a
pedophile for the united states senate
that didn't fit into tonight's narrative
but should not be forgotten from our
family to yours
we're very frightened
you're welcome i'm sorry i'm just saying
make it worth our while you know
we wrote a pretty big check for you
folks here so um
you know whatever it's fine it's fine
doesn't matter just uh i just hope
you're making the best of what we gave
you here
i would say that given the events that
preceded it the couple hundred years or
so
maybe we're about even yeah no no we
gave more oh
say can you see
by the dawn's early light
what so proudly we hailed
at the twilight's last cling me
hang on
all right that's all the time we got i'd
like to thank our sponsor the us postal
service
when you want something expensive thrown
on your porch and stolen
you want the us postal service this is
my favorite part of the game when two
drunk guys each holding a baby get into
a fist fight
you're stupid no you're stupid
oh now their wives are getting into it
they're gonna put their cigarettes in
their mouths and bump boobs
you got no class you [ __ ]
and now here comes security to kick out
the wrong person
come on miyagi take everybody outside
yeah
your experience may differ first up a
float from the veterans of future wars
[Music]
you're all doing such a great job i
wanted to play you a song i wrote about
what america means to me
when you say usa
i just say hooray and if you're not from
here
god's gonna hunt you down and give you
h.u.s.a there's only one place
at the top-secret atomic research
facility
in berlin wait a minute germany's
building weapons of mass destruction
why doesn't america go in there and kick
their asses i don't know
maybe because they don't have any oil oh
clap clap clap clap clap and the number
one thing i
peter griffin would like to say to
america we should all buy more
american-made products
which at last check are down to porn and
cheeseburgers
it doesn't look good for you senor
griffin so far you've failed everything
including the behaving like an american
at the airport test
no it wasn't bad yeah i'm on my way to
the next plane now
yeah i got a middle seat so i'm going to
see if i can switch oh
i'm going to get a big fat piece of
pizza so i got something stuff in my
face while i'm reading usa today
women muslims um everybody is not a
white man
and i mean white white so no italians no
polish just people from ireland england
and scotland
but only certain parts of scotland and
ireland just full-blooded
whites no you know what not even whites
nobody gets any rights
america in fact i got you a bunch of new
top-notch american-made stuff
what else did you buy oh a couple things
that light fixture
new heat regulator on your stove your
man bra
your garbage disposal your dishwasher
and your new cat
[Music]
i got us an injured bald eagle somebody
put cigarettes out all over them
peter that's a symbol of our country
this particular eagle is a dick
everything out of its mouth is a taunt
peter you're being ridiculous and you
need to release that eagle out into
what that eagle says
that's actually a good idea like the us
army reserves
we're completely surrounded we need
reinforcements you know who could really
bail us out
somebody who works five days a week at
enterprise rent-a-car
and there's the vietnam war memorial hey
check out that vietnamese guy giving the
business to those vietnam wretch
school board scoreboard oh what happened
to your
distract him you know like all of
america gets distracted whenever a cute
white girl dies
we regret to report that not all the
children on board the school bus
survived
we have identified the body of one
victim nine-year-old becky gunderson
no way that's uh becky gutierrez oh
that's not the news that's time to make
all those popular kids pay for ignoring
me
peter no you're just a normal high
school kid oh
hey lance it's off it's off it's off
it's off
throw this phone away lois hey what's
with this stuff
this is just the coast guard now come on
who here can pantomime driving a boat
hmm we got any boat guys here
whoa look at that you guys should be
recruiting me
now can you bounce with the waves a
little bit
oh getting kind of choppy the story on
everyone's mind continues to be the
absence of police officers in quahog
sir as a citizen how has this affected
you
the police are gone oh my god we're
finally safe
[Music]
hey you know if there's ever anything i
could do for you actually you could do
something
you could eat only dolphin-safe tuna
wait is that the brand that costs five
cents more now i can't do that
things ain't so good in america right
now which is why we're all so
fat
oh my god the president's been shot if
you ask me the president's the lucky one
how's that he doesn't have to sit
through the rest of the show
and texas is great back where i'm from a
[ __ ] guy could never have this much
fun
would you just say what technically i'm
[ __ ]
fellas fellas can't we talk this over
talking's for terrorists and blacks
in texas we execute their [ __ ] oh my
god so this is how it ends
but wait a minute i thought guns were
bad
false guns are good in fact did you know
that jesus and moses used guns to
conquer the romans
so remember guns don't kill people
dangerous minorities do
guns are extremely dangerous do not
purchase own clean operator or new guns
at any time
talking about we go places we took that
helicopter tour at busan
wow i've never seen so many boats not
near bodies of water
that park is all concrete look there's a
dog tied to our other dog
i think that guy with long hair is a
lawyer look at all those students
running for their lives
oh there's the concrete park again mr
brown what exactly
are you saying i'm saying that i
cleveland brown a black man
shot cleveland brown jr another black
man
[Music]
wait what where did everybody go you
want to make the media go away
just mention black on black crime they
get with the freaking program
it's called an automobile folks it's
much faster than a horse
oh well it appears i've been fired well
as long as i'm no longer working here
let me tell you something
you know what really grinds my gears you
america
[ __ ] you diane
not heard that uncensored
[Music]
oh well the first half the first half
had some
really tough ones for me there were some
ones in the beginning that were
super duper tough that was a challenge
yeah
oh buddy when they go for america they
they go edgy
i mean mcfarland man you know he's gonna
go all out yeah
yeah including just flat out breaking
the fourth wall and just
acknowledging things about it ma'am when
brian
um now and brian when chris started
singing the national anthem that was so
funny but then also
the breakout at the baseball stadium
with the
uh with the dudes with the babies the
why i was gonna
but yeah the first half i thought was
way way harder than the last half
one at the airport that's just so
accurate
i was transported because yeah at the
airport you know you see people from all
kinds of
areas of the world all gathered together
because they're all flying out or flying
in
and that was just a perfect
representation that one i think was
fresh to me because there there are a
couple at least like the people like the
police are gone we're finally
there like that's what i definitely
remember i had not seen the vietnam war
monument
though and that was that was a double
challenge of like
i don't want to laugh at this and also
this is like
i don't know where to land on this
offensive joke i would love to see an
american dad version of this
because yeah this had some of the really
hard like i
i was definitely there was a couple
parts where i was certainly laughing but
i was just trying to contain the noise
i was like definitely laughing when i
was like just don't let it out
don't let it out because this is really
hard yeah one like and like
crying out in just sort of outrage for
cause there are a couple of these
especially the ones from
not american character's points of view
go
hardcore on some of these jokes
oh god i wonder what the texas people
thought of those texan jokes they're all
like that's accurate
it's not my impression of you guys but
if you're from texas
when it sounds about rising it's a
documentary we're watching here
it's funny they don't look live action
[Laughter]
contributing to saving those southern
stereotypes
just messing with you yeah i found some
other chinatolops i definitely want to
try this found a south park one
and some other family guy once but then
there's also some caleb city ones in
store i was like making a list of like
you know what these are ones i would
definitely want to try out anywho
whoa yeah that first half was rough i
was like this is getting
progressively tougher which was the
toughest for you
that was definitely the samara one what
do you guys think is the toughest one
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
catch you guys soon